we all feel stuck at times what do we do
if we're just not creative we're not on
all cylinders right
there's a couple of different ways to
get unstuck
um I actually Teach an online course
about getting unstuck and we talk about
if you're stuck because you have
writer's block or procrastination
there's actual
tips and tools that you can use to get
past it and one of them
is to give yourself very short periods
of time to work 10 minutes set a timer
you can either do free writing you could
say I like that butterfly but and then
when the timer goes off get up and go
someplace else and then the next day
come back for 10 minutes or 30 minutes
and the other is really to be clear
about what your true goals are
and then make sure everything you're
choosing in your life how you're
spending your time is moving you towards
that goal
it's super important and then it's
looking at what's getting in the way of
you achieving your goals and seeing what
you can change how you can adjust your
life so that you're moving towards your
goal more efficiently
you know there's debate is writer's
block real yeah
it is it's fear
it's fear of failure it's fear of
success it's fear of imposter syndrome
I've had too many clients that had it to
say it's not real
I don't know who's saying that but my
experience is that people truly are
blocked but you can absolutely get
unblocked that is really possible
and how much of being stuck is burnout
some of it is burnout some of stuckness
is burnout and if that's what it is you
need to take a break
go to the mountains go to the seashore
go camping
um walk in the woods uh be with friends
who you like and cherish and who love
you
um be in nature I know I said that 15
times I think that's really important
step away for a little bit do things
that are fun
recharge your batteries
and don't keep pressing on yourself to
go forward forward if you're burned out
take it's it's about self-care you have
to take care of yourself you have to eat
right you have to exercise you have to
get enough sleep I don't know how you
can be creative if you're not getting
enough sleep and sometimes you have to
work two jobs I understand it but
whatever you can do to take care of
yourself really helps to combat burnout
and staying off social media for a while
what a great idea go on a social media
diet take a Hiatus because all you're
going to see are people that you see
they're succeeding God darn it why
aren't I and the pressure is too intense
absolutely take a holiday from social
media I couldn't agree with you more
when people come to you to take the
course what are some of the biggest
reasons they've become stuck
really good question
they're not able to
write new material or good material they
feel burned out they are afraid they're
afraid they'll never write again they're
afraid they'll never get another job
they're
concerned that
they don't know enough people and they
don't know how to meet enough people
they're stuck they're stuck in their
career they don't know how to reach out
and ask for help they don't know what it
takes
to meet people to they don't know their
brand and so they keep having these
opportunities and they blow their
opportunities because they don't know
how to talk about themselves
and is that off-putting then if they're
because they're they're struggling with
kind of coming up with who they are that
it's not that it's off-putting but
you're missing an opportunity for
somebody to be invested in you and
interested in you they're doing the same
thing over and over and over again and
getting the same results someone said
that's insanity and
there they think
not I have to do something different I
think I just have to do this harder and
that's a big mistake
you know we hear this invest in
ourselves and it sounds so cliche but so
many writers have invested probably time
and contests and who knows film
festivals whatever
how many of them actually take the time
to invest as cliche and sort of whatever
as it sounds in themselves
not not everybody and the truth is that
writers spend tons of money on the
course that's going to teach them how to
write the best the next best screenplay
but they don't spend the money on how
they can improve their chances not just
a script people really feel in this
business like if I write a great script
it's the golden ticket it's the Willy
Wonka golden ticket I don't have to do
anything else there's tons of other
things you have to do and learning what
those are is worth investing in and
having support for what you want to do
is worth investing in absolutely because
where people get stuck is with their
work
with their attitude with their Community
not being big enough you have to have a
ever-growing community of mutually
beneficial relationships it's learning
how to talk about themselves where they
also get stuck
is they don't have someone to be
accountable to
having that accountability is huge if
you want to make a change in your course
are you offering accountability Partners
or mentors good question
in the course we talk about finding an
accountability partner it might be
somebody from your life it might be
somebody in the class and what that
person's job is
is for you to say to them this is what
I'm going to do and this is when I'm
going to do it and they hold you to it I
talk about something called bookending
where if there's something difficult you
have to do you have to make a phone call
you have to write a scene that's so
challenging you have to go to an event
that you don't want to go to you call
your or text or email your
accountability partner first
you say I'm going to do this thing and
then as soon as you do it
you contact them again and say I did it
it's like checking a box it feels so
good do you also talk about building a
network I know networking is sort of a
that's a funny word
um Community Building Community a
community of mutually beneficial
relationships this business is based on
relationships everybody knows that the
more people you know the more chances
there are that you're going to find out
about an opportunity or an opportunity
will present themselves now there's a
lot of people that are stuck because
they don't want to go to events they
don't want to ask people for help
they're the opposite of somebody that
says hi read my script they're people
that have met people who've said I'd
like to help you and they never follow
up following up is a big thing so many
of my clients say I met all these great
people and I just let it go cold how do
I get back to having a relationship with
them and I talk about that in the course
um um
the more people you know in it in an
authentic way the more opportunity is
going to come your way